[Music]
money is on our minds that's for sure in
today's money watch we're talking about
investing how to start and how to stay
out of trouble as the markets fluctuate
investing is an important way to save
for your future last year about 50
percent of americans say that they own
stock investments can be important to
fund things like retirement and college
tuition with tax season underway
millions of americans are already
receiving refunds and those checks can
be a great way to start investing cbs
news business analyst joe schlesinger is
here to break it all down for us all
right so let's jump right in yesterday
the stocks were tumbling so why is it
important to jump in when things look
terrible and uncertain you know when we
look at other parts of the economy when
something's on sale by 10 or 15 or 20 we
get psyched but all of a sudden when
stocks are on sale and stocks are 11 or
20 lower than they were just months ago
we get really nervous so here's what you
need to do confront your fear and
understand that this is the best way to
actually reach your long-term goals you
got to build the foundation you got to
make sure that you've got your emergency
reserve fund and pay down your credit
card debt but then investing really
becomes a key component in your
financial foundation and you also say
investing is an important way to help
fight inflation yeah this is so
interesting because the whole point of
investing is to grow your nest egg
faster than the inflation rate now if
you look at the last three years if you
were an investor you've made about 115
since the bottom and that's way in
excess of the inflation rate so this is
the power of compounding of starting
early and getting your plan jumped
started okay now speaking of starting um
how do you start if you've never
invested before i think the most
important thing is if you have a
workplace retirement plan it's really
the easiest way to start so that's a
401k or a 403b or a 457. they take that
money out automatically from your
paycheck so it's really easy but if you
don't maybe an ira or a roth ira you can
open up an account pretty much anywhere
any bank or app and you can
automatically have money go from your
checking or savings into that account so
speaking of apps for companies are the
ones that you look at and say okay these
are places that are a good place to
start i like places where you can invest
cheaply in index funds so that means
that we're talking about vanguard and
fidelity and t row price and e-trade and
charles schwab and you know what there
are lots of options out there explore
them many of these places actually don't
even require minimums to start so you
literally can start with five or ten
bucks a mentor of mine once said when
learning something new remember a kiss
kiss keep it simple stupid you say keep
it simple but not put all of your eggs
in one basket right i mean keeping it
simple means maybe just using those
cheap index funds but you really want
diversification you don't want a big bet
on any single area so a little in the
stock index fund a little in a bond
index fund some cash maybe some
commodities and then don't fuss around
with it stick to your game plan all of
these companies will allow you to
actually take a risk assessment
questionnaire and will also allow you to
say how long before you need the money
these are the important metrics not
whether you beat the market when do you
need your money how much risk can you
absorb those sitting at home asking how
much do i need to start investing what
would you say to that i mean it's really
as little as zero because all of these
new companies have really basically
democratized investing meaning they have
made investing available for everyone so
you get that tax refund last year the
average tax refund was about 2 800 bucks
you get that tax refund you pay down
your debt get your money working for you
what i love about money watch is we keep
it real and we keep it jail thank you so
much good to see you jill schlesinger
thank you